la journée démarre toujours en musique
Dylan a intégré le CNTs de Châteauroux
il y a deux ans il dispose d'un logement
de fonction à distance Anne-Sophie
psychologue du sport lui propose
régulièrement des séances de préparation
mentale
le tir c'est 80 % de mental et 20% de
technique c'est aussi ce qui a séduit
Dylan à performer dans cette discipline
elle lui permettant aussi de surmonter
son handicap il est atteint depuis sa
naissance d'une hémiplégie lui
paralysant une partie de son corps je
vais prendre ma Carine 50 m parce que
j'ai un entraînement 50 m ce matin c'est
ici que toutes les nations seront
représentées en août 2024 le paradis
sportif fait partie des 23 disciplines
du programme paralympique au 7 ok se
préparer à l'entraînement demande
beaucoup de temps et d'efforts à Dylan
équipement vestimentaire table de tir
carabine caméra vidéo il doit désormais
se concentrer
dans la vie et quand j'arrivais au stand
de tirs ça va baisser en fait j'étais
calme ça m'a beaucoup aidé dans la vie
après par la suite
aujourd'hui il fait partie des espoirs
de médailles aux côtés des autres
membres de l'équipe de France qui
enchaîne des titres et beaucoup de
compétitions à l'international il a une
reconnaissance formelle de son potentiel
donc à lui de vouloir collectionner les
expériences
championnats du monde Coupe du Monde et
autres pour sa guérir parce que ça reste
un jeune tireur qui a besoin de
domestiquer sa personne le jeune sportif
est aussi moniteur et salarié à mi-temps
pour la structure l'après-midi
la cible à une nouvelle série deux fois
au stand à 600 mètres Dylan encadre ses
licenciés de la Fédération qui viennent
s'exercer au tir à longue distance il a
passé son diplôme l'année dernière le
fait qu'il travaille qui viennent en
complément dans l'équipe qui s'agrandit
au fur et à mesure permet aussi à ce
garçon de s'épanouir à travers sa
passion car si la priorité reste les
jeux dans deux ans Dylan pense déjà à
l'avenir
peut-être la suite de son rêve
ma fin de carrière de sportif pourquoi
pas être entré dans nationale au paradis
ou valide les derniers quotas pour les
jeux seront délivrés au printemps 2024